همم حتى الان ارتفع عدد الضحايا في هذه
همم في هذا الحادث الى 21 همم 21 همم من
الضحايا همم في هذا الحادث وهناك عدد كبير
من المصابين همم يزيد عن ال 20 شخص من
المصابين باصابات مختلفه منها اصابات
طفيفه ومنها اصابات متوسطه ومنها ايضا
اصابات خطيره همم هناك متابعه من من جميع
الهيئات الحكوميه ومتضمنا رئيس مجلس
الوزراء للحادث كذلك وهناك تعليمات بسرعه
استصدار تصاريح الدفن والاتصال باهالي
الضحايا لان كما علمنا همم الى هذه اللحظه
هناك بعض الجثامين التي لم يتم التعرف الى
ذويهم او همم الى من تستطيع السلطات
الاتصال لابلاغ همم الاهليه عن همم الضحيه
بعينها وبالتالي همم لا تزال جهود الانقاذ
مستمره الا انه تم استدعاء فرق الانقاذ
النهري في هذا الحدث خاصه انه يتضمن او
يعني همم هناك سقوط للحافله داخل همم
الرياح رياح او ترعه البوهيه وهي قناه
مائيه تستخدم لاغراض الزراعه على طريق اجا
ميت غمر من مراكز محافظه الدقهليه وتحديدا
امام قريه الديره كما جاء انا من الزملاء
هناك من المصادر الامنيه وهو مصادر وزاره
الصحه نحن نتحدث هنا عن همم حادث همم كبير
عدد كبير من الضحايا وغالبيه همم هذه
الوفيات من المعاينه المبدايه حدثت نتيجه
للغرق همم وذلك نظرا للدفاع الحافله الى
داخل الترعه او الرياح همم
وبالتالي همم عدم قدره الجميع على الهروب
من الحافله في الوقت المناسب بالاضافه
ال الوفيات الحادثه
متعلقه بهذا الحادث المؤثر